-So, "Oh, Hello,"
has had many lives, sort of.
-Yeah. Stage.
-Stage.
[ Both talking at once ]
But, like, the tiny stages
and then Broadway stages
and then you can see it
on Netflix.
The Broadway show and now --
-The Broadway show, yeah.
-Now a p'dcast.
-Now a p'dcast
from George and Gil
of "The Oh, Hello Show,"
and this is --
It's called
"Oh, Hello: The P'dcast,
the Life and Times of
Princess Diana, a.k.a. Di Town."
-Yeah, now, Princess Di --
And this is --
You guys are already
discussing Princess Diana.
-Diana. Yeah.
-Do you remember --
That was a big deal for yo
when Princess Diana...
-Well, I think it was a big deal
for a lot of people, Seth.
-Yeah, that's true.
-She was --
She was England's Rose,
and she was the Queen of Hearts.
-I think this is where me
being, like, just a half
generation older than you --
Because I remember the wedding
Did you watch the wedding?
-Um, no, I've seen
footage of it, obviously,
'cause I'm producing a podcast
on her life and death.
-[ Laughs ]
-So -- So, like,
I've seen clips of it, old man
But, no, I was too young
to see the wedding,
but I did get up at 5:00
in the morning Chicago tim
to watch her funeral.
-Do you -- This was done -- When
did you guys do the p'dcast?
-So, we started recording
George and Gil
talking to different guest
in the fall of 2018.
I remember 'cause the mid-term
were happening,
and we had to vote one day
And then we had to go do
"Oh, Hello: The P'dcast,
the Life and Times of
Princess Diana, a.k.a. Di Town."
Available wherever
podcasts are streamed?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But Spotify and Apple.
So, we got a bunch of guests
and we recorded all this stuff
and we were
very excited about it.
Then what happened
was the coronavirus hit,
and I think it was after we sa
Bob Dylan's 17-minute song
come out.
We thought, "Oh, you don't
have to edit so much."
-[ Laughs ]
-I really did.
Sonically, it made me
re-think editing.
And so we started discussing
that George and Gil
could put this out now,
'cause people were
essentially begging for it
and, in another sense,
they were stuck at home.
-I do --
This is just a total sidebar
You were the --
I didn't even finish
listening to Bob Dylan's
17-minute song
before I texted you.
-You had the best observatio
of it.
You said it was like
someone reading
a Wikipedia page
about John F. Kennedy
and then adding, "Hey, boy."
-[ Laughs ] I do. Yeah.
It's -- One of my favorite
Dylan moves
is, like, when he puts
dialogue in songs.
And, again, I don't know
if this is actually true.
It just seems true to me
that he always like...
-♪♪ Hello, I'm gonna go li
in Hyannis Port ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, boy, we're going
down to Dallas now ♪♪
It's a lot of, like --
It's a lot of sort of facts.
Things that are
technically true.
-But also in order to presen
the facts and dialogue,
somebody walks in the room
and tells a bunch of people.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-♪♪ On the day that it happene
a man ran in and said ♪♪
♪♪ He lives in Hyannis Por
but now he is dead ♪♪
Yeah, that kind of stuff.
That's -- I mean, that was a
off-the-cuff as cuff gets.
And that's --
-Ah, it was great.
And it was what we needed
in this time, some off-the-cuff.
-I think it was,
super early in the quarantine.
But, you know...
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ] He should do
the extended version now.
-I know. He releases it.
He goes, "All right.
You want to hear
the 38-minute one?"